have you ever started learning a
language very motivated only to find that
the motivation wears off in months
weeks or even days it has happened to me and is
still happening to me even after devoting
30 years of my life to language learning i
am well aware of how
dangerous it can be  Being the lack of
motivation for any
language goal big or small I
have also seen it with my students after
being a language coach for more than a decade
I have heard hundreds of
stories about how motivation can
run out just when we need it most
if that has happened to you  to you then
I have good news it doesn't have to
be this way how your
language learning story ends with the
right strategies you can develop
your ability to create motivation on
demand so that you have enough
for each stage of your long journey
to fluency
and today  I'm going to teach you these strategies
hello I'm nape lampariello swing
built more than speaks 14 idio  more on
this channel help people
learn foreign languages
more efficiently fast and fun
let's get started if you have already tried to learn
a language or any other skill
i am sure it is obvious that
learning a language takes effort
which may not be so obvious  for
people it's how long they have to
wait until they see tangible results
people who have
studied languages ​​in school may never
have seen results they just remember
having to complete verb tables
doing grammar and
endless exercises and copying a
vocabulary list after  other, there's little to no
fun in it all so there
's little to no motivation even
self-taught learners who
typically avoid some of the
duller basics of
traditional language learning often
find themselves stuck at an
early stage in language learning.  who spend more time with
their heads than language books
use the id  language productively
as these students can choose what and
how to learn they generally
find this period more stimulating than
traditional students but many
people still get stuck at
this stage I learn all my languages
self-taught and yet this
period of  sitting and studying is not at
all what motivates me to continue
learning languages ​​actually the
most motivating part
of the language learning process is usually what
comes after this period when
I know the language well
enough to use it when my
sitting period  and studying comes to an end this is
exactly when i start living the
language this is when i do all sorts of
fun and exciting things like
having conversations with
native speakers reading books in the
target language my target language watching movies and
tv shows in the language  of
destination to travel to the country or countries where
the language
for me is spoken  They are the most
life changing parts of learning any
language and exactly what I look forward to
when starting out as a
beginner but if you have never reached
this stage or have not reached it yet in
the language you are
currently learning how can you develop and
maintain  motivated enough to
get there how you can stay
motivated enough during the
sit and study stage to
finally see the fruits of all your
efforts
personally i use four powerful
motivational strategies which we will
examine in detail now one
imagines how you end up mastering the language
if you know how  because you'll find out how
in a few words this quote explains
exactly what has allowed me to learn
14 languages ​​for every language I've
learned I've worked hard to
figure out exactly why I needed to
learn that language and make it a
key part of my life if you want to
learn your language well  target language
you should also  figuring out why
but knowing yourself because it is not an
automatic recipe for fluency often
true because it is completely
inaccessible at the beginner level
of language learning so
you must go one step further to
borrow the motivation of that why
until  that you can make it happen for
example a common why for
language learning is to build
deep connections with
native speakers when i am a beginner who
can't put two words together in a language
making such deep connections is very
difficult or impossible to bridge the
gap between me  beginner and the
version of myself that can actually
achieve this purpose i use the power
of my imagination i
specifically close my eyes and
visualize myself months or years into the future
after i have passed the
sit and study phase and become
comfortable enough to live
my life in the language in my
mind I see myself making friends using
the language
or  i laugh i have fun alongside native speakers i
can even imagine myself
traveling across the country or visiting
famous places with new friends this is
exactly what i do with every new
language i learn to this
day i can even remember the
images i conjured up years ago while
i was learning german even before i
set foot in germany- images i
always thought of days before i sat down
for my learning sessions the
funny thing is that now even
after becoming fluent in german
and spending a lot of time in germany i
still find those images  super
motivating below i will
show you how you can use your why
to create a powerful visualization
that can fuel your motivation
for years to come first you need to find
your why you think about the kinds of things
you want to do when when is when
you will be when you are a user  expert in
your language for me normally it is to travel
and make friends but for you  it could be
different find a quiet place without
distractions and sit down with a pen and
paper take a moment to close your
eyes and try to mentally imagine yourself
doing all the things i listed do
as part of you because in the
last step try to develop this
mental image  as often as
possible ask yourself questions like who
are you with what are you doing where are you
doing it when you're doing it
once your visualization is
vivid enough write a
description in your own words it
can be as long as you like but
not mine  they are usually between 200 and 350
words keep your written visualization
with you or at least near your
study space before you sit down to learn
each day read what you have written
try to imagine it again in your
mind
if you can complete those steps and if
you can complete those  steps you will have a
powerful source of motivation that will
lead you to the desired future you can even
discover that one day your
visualization will come true as many of
mine have two focus on
systems rather than
goals most
beginning language learners are constantly
stuck asking themselves this
question over and over again when i go to
mastering the language in one go i
understand why this is
lol i used to be the same
way myself just like on any long journey it
's easy to wonder have we arrived
yet over my decades
of language learning i've learned that
this kind of  Goal-based questions
aren't helpful It
's impossible to say exactly when a
language learner will
definitely reach fluency so
obsessing about it won't
do you any good and it won't do
anyone any good instead of goal-based questions.
objectives I have found that it
is much better to ask questions based
on the system or on systems although the
questions based  ace in objectives have
answers that are often difficult or
impossible to know
system or systems based questions
have useful answers that
can usually be found in place for
immediate impact some
good system based questions
for high school students  languages ​​include for
example
when I can sit down again to
learn my target language how much
time I can spend today on
language learning how I can
ease the start of my next
learning session what you can do the
next time I don't feel motivated
to sit down and  learn all or
most of these system based questions
have unrepeatable answers
for example if you know how much time
you can dedicate to your language learning today it
is likely that you can also
determine how much time you can dedicate
to your learning tomorrow at least the
question helps you to  think about how much
time you can dedicate to your language or
learn  language indexing in the very near future
what creates value in the here and
now unlike
goal based questions over time
asking system based questions
will help you create reliable systems and programs
that will lead you towards
any goal for example  if you
develop a system whereby you
spend 30 to 45 minutes every
day learning your target language
over time you will become proficient in the language
even if you never really cared about
when you will get there
here are some suggestions that can
help you build systems  powerful
for your own learning set
aside a weekly block of time that
is completely separate from your
learning time this will be your
planning session that you will use to
reflect on your
language learning efforts of the
previous week and ask yourself system-based questions
that will improve the  efficiency
of your language learning during the
next week tr  Try to identify the
strengths and weaknesses of
your plan from your current learning plan and use this
information to modify your plan for
the future spend a realistic amount of time
learning languages
every day in addition to planning the
next system you will need
apply will settle and learn decide
how much time you can dedicate each day to
learning and mark it in your schedule
and I recommend starting with blocks of 15
30 or 45 minutes to avoid overwhelming yourself
you can always increase later
as needed developed a
contingency plan for your
daily learning sometimes life can
get in the way of your
language learning schedule have a plan in
place so that if you need to
skip a learning session
you can make up this
learning time elsewhere in your day and
make sure that even if you need to
skip a day  never
skip two days and risk breaking
your habit of a  learning in many
ways systems are more powerful
than goals because they keep you
focused on the ways you are
taking action to achieve your goal
and make the overall
learning process easier smoother and
more habitual
and target the goldilocks zone  gold when
you were a kid your parents
once told you to eat your vegetables and
whether we mean to or not
we often feel like we have to finish the
things we start simply because
we've been taught that it's the right thing to do
we finish the books we didn't
We eat meals we enjoy
and sit down to watch TV shows
that got stale halfway through
just so we can say we've finished what
we started, but while that's
often a useful rule of thumb in everyday life, it's
not always a useful one to learn.  I still
remember when a couple of years ago I
was coaching a student who
was learning German and like many
of my other students  Before I had
taught him how to apply my
two-way translation method to
shiming textbooks that normally
contain between 80 and 100 twenty
dialogues
originally it seemed that his heart
was set on applying my method in
each lesson of the book from beginning to
end however gradually  I noticed that his
passion for the assimilated lessons
began to avenge one day during a
class, Luca told me I love your method
and I love receiving but today I had
enough of those dialogues that I am going to do for you. I
think I expected him to bother me
or to say  something like get on with it or
you have to go all the way but i didn't
instead i told him he could
drop simile right away and move on to another
activity he didn't have to finish all the
lessons then because i let him
drop even though he technically had
much more material that I could cover with
ashimine because I no longer found it
fun and challenging enjoyment and
challenge must be both c  fundamental elements
of any
learning activity you do no matter what it
is to stay motivated while
learning a language you must constantly evaluate and
re-evaluate your
learning activities to ensure that you
find them fun rather than
boring you
find them neither too easy nor
too difficult
in  other words you have to make sure
that every activity you do is in
the language learning equivalent
of goldilocks zone if you
remember the story of gold starks
and the three bears you will understand the concept
as well as goldilocks didn't like
that  his soup was not too cold or
too hot you don't want your
learning activities to fall into the
extremes of too easy too
difficult or too boring although I
'm not sure there's anything wrong with
a learning activity that is
too fun identifying
the activities  of learning that is
found  within this special zone it
also has a powerful impact on
motivation author james clark
realized that when he wrote if you
feel unmotivated to work on a
task it is often because you have
strayed into an area of ​​boredom or
been  pushed into an area of ​​great
difficulty you need to find a
way to take
your skills tasks where you feel
challenged but capable so that's what
he recommends here to stay
motivated long term you need a
plan to consistently stay in
the zone  goldilocks the best
way to do that in my opinion is to
ask yourself regularly if you find
your learning activities
fun and challenging review your
language learning plan every three to
six months these two steps will help you
stay aware of the value of your
current activities  and they will remind
you to remove things regularly
to keep your learning fresh and
interesting this point of reflection and
experimentation it's something he incorporated into
everything i do as a
language student for example although i get a lot
of value from my
two-way translation method as a beginner it's not
something that continues to be a challenge as i move
towards intermediate levels
and advanced to those levels i have other
methods that are better suited to what i
enjoy and find challenging at those
times 4 build meaningful relationships
this is something i scoffed at a bit
when i talk about myself because personal but
its powerful enough to
feel  which deserves its own point to
keep you motivated in the long run you seek
meaningful relationships with native speakers
whether you are an introvert or an
extrovert i think you will
agree that humans are
social creatures much of our happiness
and well-being is derived from
interacting with people  that we
care and that cares  n for us
when as a beginning language student it
's easy to feel like there's a wall
between you and any native speaker
you can connect with or feel
too knowledgeable or too uncomfortable
to interact with them and as a
result take refuge in things
with  that you feel more comfortable
but impossible to connect with
books videos apps etc
even if you are stuck in the
sit and study stage i recommend you
find ways to build a
personal connection in your
language learning life
you can try things like visualizing
connecting  with natives
join meetup groups online or in
person hook up with a tutor find a
language exchange partner
even as a beginner you can
find value and connection in all of those
things with my experience if you are
lucky enough to form a strong bond with
a speaker  native this bond will act
as a powerful motivator that
will  it will stimulate you to get better and better at the
language on top of that you will also have a
wonderful source of bug
fixes and encouragement i have developed these
connections in almost every language you
have learned through
language learning i have met many
wonderful people with whom  I have shared
countless adventures and
life changing experiences and all of those
things together have created a wonderful
source of motivation that has kept me
learning for decades if you
build meaningful relationships with
native speakers I am sure you
too can develop an
endless source of motivation let's recap
You now have a powerful set of
four strategies that you can use
to create and sustain motivation
for years to come. This marks the
end of my trilogy of videos on
how to start learning any
language. We first cover simple steps
to get started, then we talk about the power
of translation.  on and finally we touch on the
motivation if you have seen the three videos
of the series so far thank you if
not go to the description of this video
where I have left you the links of the
other two videos you will not want to miss them
and last but  Not least if
you have enjoyed what I have shared
in this series and would like to
deepen my personal methods for learning
a language from scratch I invite you to
go to the description of this video
again where you will find a link to
my new online course  which will
provide you with even more
detailed strategies to master any language
thank you so much and as
always happy language learning
[Music]